from Google searches to Facebook post
people leave behind a large digital
footprint in the Internet age tech giant
IBM says two and a half quintillion
bytes of data are generated every day
now that's equivalent to 90 years of HD
video now to put that in perspective
that's a 2 and a 5 with 17 zeros there
you go we got it for you a new book
examines what this data reveals about us
data scientist and New York Times op-ed
contributor Seth Stephens Davidowitz is
out with everybody lies big data new
data and what the Internet can tell us
about who we really are Seth good
morning good morning great to have you
here you call Google searches the most
important data set ever collected on the
human psyche why well because people lie
consistently to just about everybody but
they tend to be really really honest to
Google something about that little white
box people feel comfortable telling
things they might not tell to anybody
else and it serves as kind of a digital
truth serum and I've studied it for five
years to learn who we really are what do
you mean the things people search for
can tell us about yeah exactly an anima
san aggregate you can see from what
people are searching what they really
think what they really want what they
really desire things that they might not
tell to anybody and all these things
like anxiety levels and that kind of
thing that's part that's one thing I
have stayed a lot and over and over
again I'm surprised by the things I've
learned so anxiety for example if you
had asked me where anxiety is highest in
the United States I would have said New
York City right Woody Allen urban
intellectuals like that's kind of the
traditional stereotype of a neurotic but
that's not true at all anxiety is
highest in rural areas in places with
lower levels of education so a lot of
our stereotypes a lot of what we think
about the world is just dead wrong I was
talking about dead wrong because I still
find this hard to believe that more
people search for porn than they do the
weather south in this country really
they kill it then doesn't surprise you
yes roses me does it surprise you
Charlie yes
no I'm not trying to put you on this
water be cute but I was very surprised
by that they told me this is a family
shelter they serve at different times
yeah they served about diet yeah also
men and women when they're talking about
their kids it's interesting that that
people will ask is my son a genius they
won't ask that about the daughter
they'll ask about the daughter she
overweight yeah that was yeah that's
that's some of the things we learn in
this we're live we lie to ourselves a
lot too so a lot of parents think that
they treat their sons and daughters
equally but if you see everybody's
anonymous in a Google searches you see
that parents tend to be more excited
about the intellectual potential of
their so times in this date and they're
done I in other words who's interested
in it who's using it well I've been
studying it for many years but uh
everything Youssef there are definitely
marketers are interested in this data
and lots of other other people as well
you also looked at forgive me how
husband's it husbands were portrayed on
social media versus some of the searches
about them on Google what did you find
yeah so it's really interesting when you
compare social media versus Google
because social media in some sense we're
the biggest liars because we're trying
to impress our friends right so we want
to look really good to them yes whereas
Google we're alone anonymous we don't
need to impress anybody we're much more
honest so if you look at the top social
media posts that start my husband is
it's my husband is the best my best
friend amazing the greatest so cute
everybody wants to say they have a great
marriage and if you look on Google when
people google about their husband it's
also amazing so that checks out yeah you
say the but but the other way searching
is my husband a jerk I don't get it they
all cheating a jerk gay annoying and so
yeah the top one is beating you say that
we're all in a date a scientist you open
with a story about your grandmother
who's 88 who said you need a nice girl
not too pretty
very smart good with people in a sense
of humor and you said grandma's drawing
from her own experiences which we all do
but Google is more reliable right so
grandma is kind of big data and I think
big data can be scary to a lot of people
they don't really know what it means but
it's actually very natural and the same
thing
that people have kind of always been
doing but now with much larger datasets
and much more honest datasets did you
find a girl yet
hi wandering I'm happy no I still I want
to end the book with with me finding
love but it didn't materialize okay well
you still have time looking for love
looking for love you talk about how men
and women are attracted to each other
what they do like if I'm attracted to a
man allegedly my pitch goes up Charlie's
discussing anything
patitos operative jokes it shows that
you're attracted to me see and what I'm
and that little laugh - that's his
little legs a little bit happy if you
have [ __ ] my jokes
right no that's amazing all the things
Thank You Seth does it make you
uncomfortable sitting here at the table
with so much sexual tension oh no no and
the body part that men search for the
most I'll leave that to your imagination
everybody lies it's on sale now where
I'd like to buy your book